we are live from New York comic-con
still yes and guess who I'm with Jon
Bernthal how you doing we have so much
so many things to talk about because
you're one of my favs consistently one
of my faves thank you thank you
comic-con let's talk about comic-con
first of all how's it been have you had
any fan er interactions yet I literally
just got here just walked in the
building and it's raining outside so I
saw some people outside which you know
it's you know give it up for them
they're like standing out in the rain
you know so I'm gonna try to bring some
umbrellas out if we can find some but
it's always good to be a Comic Con I
love Comic Con its I've always said the
comic book audience is the smartest
audience the most loyal audience and you
don't want to do it wrong yeah if you
could go down on the floor right now
cosplay does any character from any
franchise who would you go as I I don't
know just Jones you're going as Jessica
Jones like you're gonna do you're gonna
like genderbent Jessica Jones just I've
always been so obsessed with Jessica
children I love that yeah I really did
she's my favorite it's awesome okay
Ghost Recon breakpoint you I mean it's
uncanny you're amazing in it can you
talk a little bit about the motion
capture experience of that game because
it's super cool yeah I mean look I
didn't really know what to expect with a
motion capture you do look ridiculous
you know you're like in this crazy
spandex outfit with dots all over your
face and you know but you you're all in
it together all the actors are in it
together
everybody looks just as ridiculous as
the next person but you know the process
is really cool you're in a room with 800
cameras around you so it's not sort of
like standard coverage you're not it's
not your close-up than my close-up it's
it's all done in one perfect take that's
what the pursuit is and
so there's no you know you can't really
go back I really dug it's really
rehearsal driven like you've got to get
this perfect take you've got to get it
in one so the stakes are really high and
I really enjoyed I really enjoyed
working like that please tell me there
are bloopers though I'm sure I gotta see
them I'm sure there are movers I'm sure
there are bloopers but I mean that's the
thing you know you could be doing a
15-page scene and if on page 14 a line
is dropped or and you're in the wrong
place or something goes wrong in a fight
sequence you got to start over it's not
just like you can pick up the last parts
right it's really different than TV and
film but I dig that I liked it a lot
nothing makes me laugh harder than
people running around in mocap suits
it's hysterical
what's like what do you thinks the most
ridiculous thing that you had to do
while in that suit like I mean just
going to the bathroom
I mean just like like the look on
everyone's face when you're like excuse
me you know cuz if first of all
everybody's gotta wait for you which is
like a big thing with me anyway is that
really I'm trying to teach that to my
kids just to be responsible about like
when you know like your water intake and
when you got to go to the bathroom and
on work day it's very important but then
you got to run to the bathroom and
you're already in a big rush and you're
sort of humiliated that you're holding
everything up but then when you get
there you look in the mirror and you're
like look at what I look at you have all
these dots all over your face but so I'd
say that was the most ridiculous yeah
sorry guys sorry guys no you you play a
lot of like villains tough guys you did
the stint on an unbreakable kimmy
schmitt em hmm I would love to just see
you like full-on star in a rom-com
really would like to do if you can
stomach it yeah yeah I would dig you
what are you talking I just you know
I've never I mean I look
you like guys have been hit in the face
with a brick I mean look I've always
said you know I I have no kind of
aspirations as far as the type of
character I play I just I want to work
on the best stuff with the best people
possible in this movie that's coming out
Ford Ferrari I play Lee Iacocca it's
totally different you know I am NOT the
one racing the cars I'm the one in the
boardroom talking a lot yeah and it is
it's it's it's refreshing and I'm
excited I have something coming out that
BJ Novak wrote and directed that I'm so
proud of that I think it's gonna be so
great that's gonna be a totally sort of
different thing for me so so we'll see
so you don't have like dream roles you
kind of just see what I think the cool
thing about what what I do is the dreams
are kind of out there you know I don't
know what that's the best part about
dreams you don't know what they're gonna
be you know III think that you know that
those roles are out there and when they
come I know it immediately and I know
that's the one that I want to go after
yeah well in in Fort Mercer are you're
more behind the desk but did you get to
do any like ride-alongs or anything like
that because I would just be like take
me as fast as you know a lot of the
drivers they're the best drivers in the
world and a lot of the drivers on that
movie also drove on baby driver where I
got to drive along with them so I've had
my time you know but it's it's
absolutely I think that the stuck
community is the the most sort of
underappreciated community in Hollywood
they they're just fabulous the level of
talent is staggering and those stunt
drivers the things that they can do is
just it'll blow your mind yeah I'm big
when I was a kid I wanted to be a NASCAR
driver my daughter wants to do that
really yeah yeah
for but like she you know she's like
she's super into it yeah I'm about to
buy her a go-kart yeah you gotta like
take her to a race my mom like pulled me
out of second grade to go meet Jeff
Gordon I got a lot of Russian for that
that's cool Delaware oh yeah that's
right oh yeah cuz you go to the beach
yeah worked at Rehoboth yes I did yes I
went to the picking fish you worked at
the pig and fish no was it Nikolas Wow
why'd you get fired I was driving the
delivery motorbike in an unsafe manner
okay so how was bamm-bamm
he was great they Mitch I wish you could
be here right now but BAM Bam's man I
just saw of it they just sent me a video
Bam Bam with my daughter yeah I mean
every time Bam Bam makes an appearance
he steals the show like headlines
everywhere right on I mean when you did
the e3 yep and you gotta give it up to
yourself like they recognized I mean
they were like all right John let's push
you to the side there's the real son
they recognized recently they've asked
me they're like do you want to bring him
to every other event that you do you
know and I'm just it's really out of
jealousy that I'm keeping him at home
now yeah I have I have like puppy fever
right now yeah well I'm so bad get one I
just say good dog everybody should
rescue dog there's so many wonderful
dogs at shelters looking for homes and
they will make you so happy
get yourself a little pit bull puppy you
know what I mean everything will come
right well congratulations on everything
you're the best you're the best thanks
so much Delaware
[Music]
[Applause]
you